hey shag nation it's Greg Alva here with
Courtney scotch right we actually shot a
whole intro already now we're gonna
really capture the magic because the mic
wasn't plugged in good thing I caught it
before we filmed the reaction party what
did we highlight here this is Kourtney's
first time being here
that's numero uno you might have seen
her on my brother's channel Jabby Kawai
that's his biological name she's been on
there plenty of times they're really
good friends because best friends
[Music]
Courtney and I get along pretty well and
I've always wanted her to come on I
found out she was like a pretty big
comic book reader she does comic on
every year she actually knows comics so
I thought it'd be fun to do some
Avengers videos with her the thing
though is it's been a long
work-in-progress to have her to come on
because she is highly allergic to my
cats specifically I felt guilty for
three weeks after that 3o weeks I
counted that's usually what it takes for
me to get over something you're here
today
and we're good I was started off with
Tom we're doing a prediction video but
before that maybe this will help us out
with our prediction video there's an
infinity war family featurette released
from the Marvel Studios channel
themselves and I thought we should check
this out first and then right right in
the family we're in the family we pay to
be in the family we've seen all their
food we've done a lot of money
it
join up with the Avengers
[Music]
[Laughter]
back to despair people those are all
dead yeah they're gonna can the
franchise even though they tease it in
the trailers and I wasn't really
thinking about it was the companionship
that will probably form between
star-lord and Thor isn't sterling he's
saying you're a do bet that star large
part of God or something like that all
right
after guardians of the galaxy - it all
depends technically is based on
guardians - he is just because like ego
is no more doesn't mean he just doesn't
have any powers I don't think nobody has
any powers anymore but he's technically
half alien but they're gonna be able to
bond though over that that's a
commonality trait that's what we have in
common yeah this whole family feature
like the fact that they're showing you
how they're weaving everybody together
that to me is really exciting because I
love seeing star-lord with the guardians
and I love hearing like deny Guerra who
plays a co yet like talking about how
she developed a bond with elizabeth
Olsen plays Scarlet Witch and then
Scarlett Johansson that's cool it's a
Charlie wait scar Johansson who are they
talking I'm hoping you're gonna be like
hope when they get that here one thing I
really liked about the Dora Minaj and
I've talked about this in other videos
is how those are characters of women who
were not like battered or abused in any
way they were just strong you know they
want expect it to be docile they yeah
that was their role like they were the
royal bodyguards of the King exactly
that to me was so powerful and one thing
there's a vendor's infinity war things
have not been doing is pushing like the
theme or topic of female empowerment
front and center at all but they do talk
about that here they the way they're
mentioning it is strong female
characters I'm like oh you know it's
something I hadn't even really put much
thought into but I feel like we're gonna
get that in this movie there because if
you think about it first you get Black
Widow Black Widow they get Scarlet Witch
then they've introduced a Koi yay and
all these and mantis and here Oh mantis
grab our yeah and Gamora forgot about
nebula
hila who now I guess we're assuming
she's on the good guys yeah just like
the comics I love what they're doing I
love seeing women fighting alongside
each other yeah a lot of times in
comedies or and sometimes in drama you
have they pick a woman against another
one you know in order to to showcase
this leg that's right yeah it's not this
is way more interesting because I want
to see them all battle and see what they
can do in order to like protect the
globe what I like too about this is most
of the time these infinity war spots are
like epic and Harper hears something
like positive and it was nice to see
that opening bid with Drax making fun of
star-lord and Thor because you're like
oh yeah that's right gonna be comedy in
this movie but we're not really getting
too many hints of the comedy as much as
I love the darkness and the epic scale
and all that like I'm Jack for this
movie so heartwarming video yeah see
like getting like snippets of seeing
characters that we've never actually
seen together before I guess darken
Doctor Strange I'm excited for that
pairing sherlock holmes's mm-hmm what do
you say we film another video or we have
some actual for addictions about it so
you can subscribe become part of the
reject nation click that notification
bell cuz subscribe buttons don't mean
anything you could check out Courtney
Scott right and that's your Instagram
[Music]
Courtney is know you in there and right
is where the W every time I try to
contact you I forget that and then I
asked ya